has there been a fan that was a little
unhinged like a crazy person maybe they
got a tattoo or they're like throwing
their [__] draws up at you or
something I had to do last night who
kept calling my government name and like
from the crowd yeah and like was like
like just saying stuff at me too like I
don't like I don't love Brody follow me
saying some crazy ass [__] what's he
what was he saying to you like Interview
with the Vampire type stuff
was he like yo I'll suck your dick bruh
there you go
what's the next question
you gotta clear it up now what did he
say
he said what'd you say interview with
the vampires yeah let's leave it there
but what's the next question